sur France 2 c'est l'événement de la
rentrée littéraire du moins pour les
amateurs de BD le dernier Astérix sort
aujourd'hui dans les librairies la
nouveauté c'est qu'il est signé par le
tandem huderzo gosini une première
depuis la mort de ce dernier en 1977
Olivier linouza Sophie jou et
[Musique]
Christoph l'heure de la rentrée des
classes ouvrez vos cahier première leçon
de l'année comment faire du neuf avec du
vieux
Astérix est la rentrée gauloise un
ouvrage tiré à un million et demi
d'exemplaires distribué en France et en
Belgique c'est quand même un classique
de la bande dessiné classique
effectivement toujours du monde l'album
qui sort aujourd'hui est en fait une
réédition actualisée mis à part de
aventures inédites la BD RAC 12
histoires courtes publié dans les années
60 70 notamment dans le journal
Pilote des choses assez anciennes que
les jeunes générations ne connaissent
pas que peut-être même les générations
de 40 ans nont pas connu non
plus et qui m'amusait de de
montrer en espérant quand même que ça
puisse les
intéresser l'âge d'or en ce tempslà
udero dessinait gosini mettait du
champagne dans les
bulles qu'est-ce qui a fait le succès
d'asérix je dirais
que ce que tu vas dire je dirais que le
dessin surtout a
jouer
surtout en
partie à l'époque les auteurs savaient
se mettre en scène une idée naissance
d'un
personnage balade dans un port breton où
l'on croise des individus gros en
couleur n cherchant essentiellement à
amuser le public et je dirais que il n'y
a pas d'autre motivation que celle-là
aujourd'hui gosini n'est plus la magie a
disparu mais Astérix est toujours une
mine d'or déjà 300 millions
d'exemplaires vendus dans le monde un
filon bon à exploiter on peut vivre
retirer dans un village depuis 2000 ans
et être à la page le gaulois est moderne
a le sens des affaires par
l'Anglais
[Musique]
ismy voà Astérix aujourd'hui dans toutes
les librairies c'est la fin de ce
journal